he's your media producer JD and I have
the exact same taste JD and I have a
mutual friend JD you have celebrity
friends I mean I I a couple I'm your
wing man I'm here to set you up we can
have a normal conversation
okay we're trying to get your
[__] mind right we want to get
you right talk about interacting with
the celebrity oh Hollywood hardmire
Hollywood Harmeyer over there
oh
I'll show you how much of a fan he is
I'll give him a quiz on the show you're
not gonna know this though who's the
host of The Intern show oh uh uh uh [__]
you're not gonna not JD no not JD no um
JD come on in let Ryan meet
this is the opposite life you've heard
you might be able to give me in the
China Club yeah baby I could you know
what happened to him the other night
this would never happen I did kind of
hear this story yeah JD who's on the
internet with somebody and he had a girl
he was going to meet there she put him
on the list put him unless he got there
and they wouldn't let him in because he
was a nerd wait wait you didn't drop the
stern you didn't like say no I I don't
like to do it that should be your go-to
I don't want to be that douchey I feel
like a douche if I did that that's what
makes you feel like a douche
the most unbelievable thing I heard is
JD and Ryan Philippe hooked up Ryan
ability and and JD so how do you hook up
with Ryan Phillippe well I saw him and
and uh he goes yeah yeah I'll take you
out you know buy drinks and stuff
are we going to Club at one point Ryan
introduces me to some hot chick yeah and
I go hey you know how you doing you know
my name is JD and whatever and
the chick yeah asked Ryan you know why
are you introducing me to him
the trick-ass Ryan you know how long
have you known each other he goes like
you know like a week and a half and uh
so the chick goes uh hey you know this
is my sister over here
so I read your sister and I go hey how
you doing and and the sister goes oh you
know what I gotta go over here for a
second I'll be right back and she split
up both chicks walk away and it was just
it was like that was it for the night
yeah I had a great night hey at least
you got to talk to Chick
if you want to meet JD I'll introduce
you to I would love to you want to meet
him I would love JD come in and say
hello to Will Arnett he's a fan of yours
there he is yeah hahaha your dream boot
has arrived what nothing else
all right goodbye
that he can understand so he can take it
with us don't back off your point yeah
what did you say I was just saying your
dream boat has arrived like you know how
you dream about it nothing it was dumb
no it was done well you obviously have
good fashion sense don't you think this
this kid could sort of clean himself up
a little bit and by the way it wouldn't
take a lot of money if you could go to
Urban Outfitters look at those pants JDS
the jeans come on man old man jeans Limp
Biscuit is done right okay I like the
Milky song is the facial hair working
for him I think yeah no it's it's not
that effective but you know it wouldn't
take much I'm not looking to be
effective no but he's he he's a he's a
good person this is just a manifestation
of some sort of you don't feel like
you're deserving a good clothes or a
good look well I don't know about that
yes
you just said head into something if I
knew you better I'd say hey JD is a
friend of mine and I don't like to see
you treat him this way say that stop
giggling and listen do what will says I
think this guy's answer I say I'm not a
friend of mine no what I would say that
JD is a friend of mine JD is a friend of
mine so stop being mean so stop being
mean to him that's it
obviously your social skills will
constantly uh belittled on the show yes
yeah tongue-tied and incoherent and
incomprehensible to a lot of people yes
would you be willing to hang out with JD
I can actually turn him into a pimp I
would like to situate you no I don't
want to be situated I'll be much happier
you know what his name is the shitty
situation Vern what is it with him you
could see his demeanor right is it that
he's a sad song
just be yourself no that's the problem
that's bad advice for him JD and I have
a mutual friend this girl is smitten
with JD nothing has happened if you get
a little bit of confidence I think you
have a real shot there she likes me as a
friend Jerry I don't look at people
directly you don't look at people
directly you say do whatever you want
treat me how you want take what you want
I'll take whatever's left over you're
right just look people in the eye I have
a positive outlook do a little shave go
to the gym all right listen I want to be
a filmmaker make a film I know I know
George I know you need that passion the
want to do you can't just dream you've
got to do it can I leave please he
didn't know how to use chopsticks and so
we were going to teach him how to use
chopsticks and he spent an hour and
change trying to learn how to use we
will totally change the outfit new shoes
some jeans I will get him a haircut some
gel have you cut your [__] hair yet
have you ever thought about getting an
astringent for oily skin you [__] were
you shocked when JD announced he hadn't
washed his sheets for a year it kind of
irks me at that point you're dealing
with feces semen blood JD tell Seth how
long you went a year
once a week bro you shouldn't be living
in New York City I can see you in rural
Pennsylvania you get like a nice Old
Colonial house and get like a cello in
your room golly plays cello every
afternoon from four to six uh don't
disturb JD then you know I don't want to
hear it anymore you can't take this JD's
walking out he's walking again
JD went to Los Angeles to direct an
episode of It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia
not a full episode yet I mean the only
sort of [__] ups if you want to call
them [__] ups when you're supposed to
yell action you would yell go well I did
that once once yeah it's all right yeah
why did you abandon action oh it's just
whatever came to mind you did sound
excited when you called for Action
though that's a very powerful thing but
action
I think he could have been a little more
enthusiastic for the actors
[Laughter]
let's take a get when uh Frank comes
back in yeah
[Music]
guys sounds like we got an interpreter
there that's the first idea
so JD why would we take it from this all
right
totally ignored your direction yeah they
changed though they asked your opinion
you said no take it from the line and
then then they just said take it from
the top all right I mean easy going
director sounds like the assistant
director's butting heads with you no hey
[__] you I tell you to take it for an
alarm
how did they introduce you to like Danny
DeVito like how do they explain why
you're there well I think uh from Danny
DeVito I'm like I don't want to [__]
be part of like some douchebag coming in
here and giving me his special day of
directing so they probably lied to him
and said you were dying of something and
you're like from make a wish I don't
know about that all right oh hello young
man how much longer do you have son
[Applause]
why is he giggling because [__] you I
have a week to live I don't know
the guys on the show kept telling me I
went to the set on Thursday they kept
saying you know JD's really good he
showed up with some good ideas and he's
a good listener like you were a
different JD you could articulate a few
things and you were able to sort of
speak their language oh I don't know
about all that but
I came I guess prepared I came with a
sort of plan and uh it was executed uh
pretty much close to us as uh I I
thought it would be
you know who I am
yeah
you know exactly who I am
I'm not JD Harmeyer
come on come on
by the way your greatest role ever is
when you do your JD impression ah it's
just yeah I don't know
but I know you're upset with JD because
he never thanked you uh for doing an
impression of him at the birthday show
you do have results yes I did you did
thank him I
I don't know what's going on with you
too I hope you work it out I went to go
visit him before I came on the show and
he was masturbating in his little
cubicle did you do your impression when
you talk to him wait what are you doing
there
you're not supposed to masturbate like
this like you're rolling it use one hand
like a man
well you're really something the way you
work social media someone said you were
tweeting back and forth with Samantha B
I've gotten to be friendly are you
direct message yeah I'm sliding into his
DM you do stay in touch with JD I do
yeah I've direct message Amy Schumer
before how does that happen she saw her
following me JD here thanks for fire
thanks Sherm through DM we have been
friendly for years and years he's good
right when he writes it's bright it's
funny it's quick it's articulate I am a
much better Communicator when I'm not
staring at someone you become Brad Pitt
on Twitter he's better on texting he
does have a terrible handshake it's like
you can feel how many times he's jerked
off yeah it's the only part of his body
has any muscle yeah you are in a text
chain with Hollywood writers and what
are you texting mostly about movies and
what what DVDs they got fascinating
you're the person whose name comes up
most as a name drop from this show
really people's way into this show is
that they know JD you're friends with
Natalie Maines from the Dixie Chicks see
a documentary we text each other about
it [__] lunatic O.J Simpson followed
me on Twitter OJ only follows 34 people
and JD is one of them I think you
secretly love it I don't no I do not
look out Samantha B was up here doing
some stuff for us she saw JD and they
had a conversation we were lucky enough
to tape it oh and it's every bit as
awkward as you think it would be hi it's
really nice to see you uh yeah I think
that we can have a normal conversation
I'll make this God oh you know I should
bring this up oh okay you know on the
way oh my god oh [__] maybe I shouldn't
say that okay we're 13 seconds in I
don't know what the [__] he's mumbling
about
like she goes hey JD it's really nice to
see you and you go oh yeah
yeah my brain locks up or whatever and I
can't I just don't know what to say at
certain times or I can't physically say
it she goes hey nice to see you you
don't think to say nice to see you too
no for whatever reason I feel weird
saying it I don't know on the way to go
to your show I ended up seeing like a
dead body on the sidewalk
like someone had just jumped off a
building oh my God
what are you laughing about
you wouldn't believe it because it was
as awkward and I didn't it was
I laugh when it's awkward it was really
weird like I had to go to your show so I
basically walked by you were like I'm
just gonna want to listen
I saw other people contacting police and
there's only so much you can do yes this
guy was oh I don't want to give him I
don't want to say were you shaking was
it it oh yeah horrible oh yeah
um yeah so uh yeah how's your day so far
this is 100 the highlighter oh wow that
I just feel bad for you no all right I
gotta go now thank you very much okay
here we go thank you nice seeing you
again really nice to see you all right
we had to duck out so fast I can't sit
there all day wow do you have actual
feelings JD oh yeah yeah of course
I can I get the most all the time so how
did you feel seeing Samantha be it was
very nice to see her that would have
been a thing to say
[Music]
Eric Andre like every year for his
birthday has a birthday party that he
sells tickets to it's a show JD and
Blitz right you guys win yes yes oh yeah
so he rents out this knockdown Center in
Queens packs in 3 000 people the party
gets set up like a music festival with a
main stage a bunch of smaller areas to
check out and then he has things like a
torture room with people performing
bondage and discipline as soon as they
arrive John tried to take JD into the
torture room it was guarded by a woman
with a bull whip let's go I'm not
getting whipped you're not gonna get wet
even looking back here we could get
easily killed I don't want to get
whipped it's for your job they're
allowed to go there I don't care I'm not
going back come on you got to be the
first to go no I don't it's for your job
no it's not for my job see Brave
just come on you guys have kind of a sub
Dom relationship like you're always
torturing JD then JD interviewed Eric
Andre after his big set on stage what do
you what do you need me to say how are
you feeling what is the feeling right
now all my orifices are wide open yes
I've seen you offered yourself in many
ways yeah yeah I always offer you all my
holes I know you don't wash your bed
sheets but I offer you all my holds the
guy's got to clean up his act that's
your night no no I'm your wing man I'm
here to set you up what do you need get
them in I'm not doing anything uh we're
gonna drug you tonight yeah we got a
drug get it out no no no anybody can
hear me drug JD tonight just give them
whatever whatever he doesn't want give
it to him
we will be back tomorrow JD's gonna
smoke weed for the first time he's never
smoked weed Never Enough he's 56 years
old no how old is he JD he's 39 he's 39
yeah let Jennifer see him give him some
advice you're gonna smoke weed for the
first time uh yes I'm 39 years old you
really haven't yeah I really have not
look at him do you have any advice for
him just pace yourself a couple of hits
a couple of hits and see what happens is
it gonna be the worst day of your life
or the best day of your life okay that's
what I'm worried about you know go where
you'll live what should he be smoking
the first time smoker said I think for
someone who just never smoked weed you
might want to start with something
strong to make sure you actually feel
something because you might not but
again one [__] yes hit yes if you hit
this [__] one time yeah your
[__] ass gonna be done yeah
your FIFA appearance is Gonna Change
yeah your style of women gonna change
your hair gonna get long by the way I
should mention JD is wearing a special
shirt for his introduction keeping up
with the theme today he says his plans
what's with this shirt
on that [__] or something that
we recognize ain't no cactus in the hood
of the JD this is your moment dude you
got two experts here is there anything
you want to know yeah some people were
saying doing Indica because of
sativa will like help the paranoia go
it's like it's possible this is the main
thing don't think yeah just have a good
time and just enjoy like when you think
that's when this [__] go wrong because
then you start thinking about stupid
[__] like why is my heart beating fast
why why
go into a wood I'm gonna get my dick
sucked and then it's a different emotion
you know what I'm saying go into every
situation with that that is but you know
what Seth you are you're laughing at JD
like he's a [__] a little bit right
okay I'd say it is arguably hilarious
for a 39 year old person with the job
you have surrounded by the people you're
surrounded with to be so afraid of
taking one hit a week you know we've
introduced them to a lot like you got
laid the first time on this show right
we got you later we don't need to go
through
what it feel like okay what's your pull
out game like you're wearing a rubber
yeah of course no you or you didn't get
none then
you ain't been lazy yeah
thank you
no one on my staff ever dates anyone
famous I try with my guys when we had
Khloe Kardashian here she had the
paparazzi waiting for her I said Chloe
would be okay if JD walked out with you
and held your hand because we could
start a rumor that JD's going out with
you and she goes sure did you see the
latest JD from the Howard Stern Show
like we tried to get something going
JD's holding her hand the whole time not
one [__] newspaper reported it no
pictures he even hugged me he tried to
sell it more she hugged me too and
nothing even the Press looked at JD went
there's no [__] way then I try to set
you up with Elliot's pictures gal Ashley
do pray with your day JD
JD's super hot hi JD Katie
I I don't
I don't know what type of guys you're
into whatever I would take you out to
like a date or something you know what I
don't know I will give you my business
card which also has the greatest gift
ever which is my cell phone number on
the back I love that okay guy came up
with that JD was on his date with Ashley
Dupre he made the lead story on TMZ
oh my God all right that was good calm
down by the way you know who's in love
with Mel B who JD I love JD hey JD you
want to meet Mel B no he doesn't want to
meet me he will she has curves in all
the right places
she's the hottest spice girl thank you
for the compliment I love you Melvin I
saw on the newyorkpost.com they had a
big picture with you and Jennifer
Aniston we launched the real thing and
you guys were featured here like you're
almost like a couple yeah you know what
I mean this is the start I like to
apologize to Jennifer JD and J A
everybody in the stern Universe loves JD
and sees him as like a little brother we
have a tender place in my heart for you
does that make you feel weird no not at
all you entertain me greatly he loves JD
I love you JD I love him I love him hey
big round of applause for JD
good for you dude
oh